bonjour à tous je voulais vous parler de
ce que vaut la gratuité la gratuité
c'est par définition ce qui ne vaut rien
pourtant je suis sûr que vous tenez à
vos idées que vos idées ont une valeur
et que la valeur de vos pensées définit
votre vie j'en suis sûr en 1976 deux
artistes cristaux et sa femme jeanne
claude on invente is running for in fine
c'est une immense toile de nylon qui
mesure cinq mètres de haut et qui se
déroulait dans le paysage sur 40 km de
long et pour terminer sa course se
glisser dans l'océan
ces gens là après avoir terminé leurs
interventions plastiques des artistes
après avoir fait beaucoup parler d'eux
ils ont nettoyé le paysage
ils ont enlevé la bande de nylon et tout
est revenue nickel pas de problème
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ces gens là
ils ont simplement interrogé le regard
qu'on peut avoir le regard que vous avez
sur votre quotidien sur le paysage ou
autre chose
ces gens là ont donc c'était en 76 ces
gens là se sont donc retrouvés dans la
lignée de ce qu'on était les activités
des hommes dans l'histoire de l'humanité
par exemple 300 ans avant jésus-christ
les mayas avaient fait déjà des dessins
des dessins de plusieurs kilomètres de
long au milieu de paysages les mayas
avait déjà peut-être des soucis de
communication pour l'instant ça reste un
mystère
l'histoire de l'humanité le plein de ce
que sont les traces des gens qui ont
inventé des choses en particulier
l'image et on peut se rappeler que la
france continue pas mal de merveilles de
ses traces en particulier lascaux la
sfio lascaux c'est moins 18000 en
chauvet qui a été découvert ya pas très
longtemps c'est moins trente deux mille
ans mais je sais que dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
il nous manque toutes les traces
sensible des hommes toutes les 13 106
que je veux dire le rire la pensée la
musique peut-être y dans une
intervention comme celles des cristaux
qui est une intervention gratuite pas si
gratuite que ça me diront certains eh
bien je suis sûr qu'il ya un acte
politique majeur
c'est à dire arriver à ce que les gens
communiquent s'interroge puissent
échanger au contraire en 1961 des hommes
ont inventé le mur de berlin le mur de
berlin c'est plus 40 km c'est 155 km de
long mur de berlin
ça s'appelait le mur de la honte le mur
de berlin est tombé en 1989
vous pouvez imaginer très bien ce que
sont les coûts de construction de
maintenance les courants vie oscille en
vies humaines
et quelle a été la force des gens qui
ont construit
ce mur monsieur encore plus impressionné
par la force des gens qui ont été
capables de faire détruire se muera
entre les états unis d'amérique et le
mexique
vous avez un mur aujourd'hui qui en
cours de construction encore c'était en
2002 il a commencé une mesure 1300 km de
long en israël aujourd'hui on érige un
mur mesure pour l'instant 700 km de long
qui mesure à peu près huit mètres de
haut par endroits où dans un exemple
aussi récent en 1981 au maroc le mur de
sable museau de sable du sahara
occidental mesure 2700 km de long tous
ces murs qui sont bien entendu
surveiller elles sont là pour séparer
pour faire des limites créer des bd
différence enfin qu'en tout cas voilà il
s'agit de barrières de clôture on a
aussi un exemple immense c'est celui la
muraille de chine qui a été commencé en
221 avant jésus-christ et qui s'est
terminé au 17e siècle
ça veut dire deux mille ans de
construction d'une barrière qui mesurent
6700 km de long aujourd'hui cette
barrière qui était quand même une
barrière militaire est déclarée
merveilles du monde
j'ai l'impression que ça fait partie des
symptômes de notre société d'imaginer
que les barrières militaires puissent
devenir des merveilles du monde
dans le monde il y à d'autres murs
encore qui existe la liste est longue
d'autres sont en cours de réalisation et
d'autres sont en projet ils sont
toujours de plus en plus grand de plus
en plus efficaces donc tous ces murs
toutes ces barrières tout ces clôtures
toutes ses murailles tous ses remparts
ont en projet un seul but c'est de
diviser de séparer de différencier
d'isoler des peuples des cultures des
ethnies des hommes des femmes les
mobiles on s'arrange toujours pour en
trouver géopolitique territoriaux
militaire défensif qui esquive au tsar
au contraire lorsque le christ on
invente isaurine vince leur projet
c'était justement d'aider une prise de
conscience qui était orienté sur une
force de vie dans une logique pacifique
avec la terre et avec les gens
communiqué pour essayer de parler de la
beauté certainement c'est pas valable
pour tout le monde mais en tout cas ce
principe là était leur point de départ
une des fonctions dollar serait donc la
gratuité une part de gratuité
je sais su pas tout à fait naïf que
l'art n'est pas gratuit vous pouvez en
témoigner aujourd'hui avec marché de
l'art qui sait jamais si bien porté les
plus grands profits aujourd'hui sont
ceux du marché de l'art bien au delà de
toute lisse de toutes les autres de tous
les autres secteurs
pourtant dans la contemplation la
générosité la beauté les sentiments
l'humanité la gratuité semble avoir
gardé une petite place dans les
territoires confiné des créateurs de la
philosophie la gratuité et le
détachement sont effectivement à
l'opposé du fonctionnement de notre
monde de santé centré sur le profit le
développement outrance efficacité et la
compétition pourtant
exister c'est pas si facile mais existe
et c'est être là simplement sans
nécessité sans explication sans raison
je sais que des artistes y croit encore
mais d'autres certainement sont capables
d'y croire aussi continuer de croire à
ce que vaut la gratuité dans la musique
dans l'écriture dans la création général
là on peut croiser la part sensible de
l'humain l'espoir réside certainement en
tout cas pour moi dans ce territoire là
territoires sensibles dans ce coeur qui
palpite les traversent les siècles le
temporel de la poésie
aujourd'hui le maire c'est le message de
l'art pour moi est justement là dans la
gratuité et dans la ballade dans la
valeur de la gratuité
lorsque vous avez vu les quelques
minutes du film
vous avez vu à peu près la concentration
dans laquelle je suis ton chemin pour
accéder à ce territoire singulier
cette victoire est difficile c'est
territoire de l'âme
en fait il faut abandonner tout tout ce
qui est la réalité
vous m'avez vu dans les images à la fin
peindre un arbre
ça fait trente ans que je pars il
continue de m'émouvoir